-I have some very big news.
I am dropping a shoe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's it. That's it.
I'm dropping --
I'm dropping a sneaker.
[ Drum roll ]
Yeah, I'm dropping --
[ Chord plays ]
No, you can play a big one
if you want to.
-Okay.
-Clang.
[ Rim shot ]
Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Why wouldn't you give me
the full I'm dropping --
-Let's see the shoe first.
-Yeah, let's see it first.
[ Laughter ]
-All right, check this out.
This is the real deal.
So, I've always --
Wait, a little backstory.
I always wanted to have
my own sneaker.
And I always -- I've talked to
a bunch of people
about doing stuff in the past.
But, then, I met these geniuses
over at MSCHF.
Do you know those dudes?
-Yeah.
-They're the guys that --
they did the Lil Nas X sneaker.
They're called MSCHF,
so it's spelled M-S-C-H-F.
-So you did a sneaker
that has a little drop
of comedian blood in every --
-No, there's no blood in mine.
There's no blood in my sneaker.
-Okay.
-There's no blood in my sneaker.
But, we -- we -- we talked
to Dan Greenberg.
So, they're out of Brooklyn, met
with Dan, and we were talking
about all these dumb ideas.
And I go, "Look,
if I'm going to make a shoe,
it's got to be different.
It's got to change the game.
It's got to be something
totally different."
And we figured it out.
All right?
[ Drum roll ]
We're about to show it to you
now for the first time.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't even know
if I'm ready for the --
I don't know if I'm ready for
the -- I'm not ready for the --
I'm not ready for the drum roll
yet.
Here it is.
This is the MSCHF Gobstomper.
[ Drum roll ]
Jimmy Fallon Edition.
Now, look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Here's the idea behind this.
Ready for this?
-Sure.
-Ready for this?
You're going to freak out.
All right, check this out.
So, you open this --
I'm unboxing for the first time.
Yeah.
Oh, get ready.
No, get ready.
You're going to freak out.
Dude, you're going to freak out.
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, look -- now look, now look.
Now check this out.
So, it's like a skater shoe,
right?
So this is the shoe right here,
[ Audience ohs ]
The idea behind this shoe
is this --
the more you wear it and wear it
down and break it in,
there's different layers
of colors in the sneaker.
[ Scattered applause ]
Like a Gobstopper.
That's why it's called
Gobstomper.
Like a Gobstopper.
So let me just show you,
this is the sneaker
when you just first wear it.
And you can wear it all around.
You can skate with it.
You can dance with it,
whatever you want to do.
And then, when it gets worn
down, look at this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-There you go.
-Yeah.
That's what I'm talking about.
Every shoe will look different.
It's called the Gobstomper.
It's going to drop, that's what
they call it, next Thursday,
July 28th at 1:00 P.M.
Eastern Standard Time.
They'll be sold
in a 24-hour draw.
So go to MSCHFsneakers.com.
Or just search MSCHF Sneakers
in the App Store.
It's the Gobstompers.
I'm so excited about this.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪